stellen sie sich mal vor sie sind
verkäuferin im supermarkt wollen morgens
in ruhe die regale einräumen und dann
das statt frischem obst sind die
bananenkisten voller
plastiktüten mit koks das hier ist
übrigens nur mehl liebe zu schauen genau
das ist in vielen supermärkten in bayern
passierte und so flog der große
drogendeal der albanischen
rauschgiftmafia auf dutzende verdächtige
werden festgenommen und jetzt ist das
urteil auch rechtskräftig und die
beweise also 1,5 tonnen kokain sind nur
noch asche
es knistert und knackt stadt durch die
nase ziehen 1,5 tonnen kokain durch ein
schornstein in bayern operation
schneeschmelze läuft hier verbrennt das
lka rauschgift im wert von 270 millionen
euro an einem geheimen ort begleitet von
schweren jungs und vier staatsanwälten
in jahre lang wird koks in höchster
reinheit vor allem aus brasilien über
hamburg zu uns geschmuggelt in
bananenkisten und die masche scheint
perfekt in deutschland kommen die grüne
bananen in reife heilen die hand länger
wissen wo sie sind brechen ein und
klauen des koks aus den kisten ich halte
hier in meinem in meiner hand an diesen
kokain ziegen und die täterseite hat in
unserem ermittlungsverfahren paraguay
diese ziegel in bananenkisten
eingebracht und im selben menge wie die
ziegel in die befüllten bananenkisten
eingebracht wurden wurden die früchte
entnommen so dass es nicht auffällt vom
gewicht her dass da was anderes drin ist
als ursprünglich vorgesehen die
schmuggler schon 2017 die lager für ihre
einbrüche vertauschen landen die kooks
kisten in supermärkten die polizei
überführt dutzende verdächtige jetzt
sind die langen gefängnisstrafen
rechtskräftig bei 1000 grad kann das
weiße gold endlich verbrannt werden das
dealer herz weint klar ist aber die
ermittler haben die krummen dinger
endlich beendet
ja und das verbrannte koks das wiegt so
viel wie ein auto und wir schauen uns
einmal an wie die drogen überhaupt ihren
weg nach deutschland gefunden haben der
in kolumbien und bolivien sitzen die
drogenkartelle vom hafen von puerto
bolivar verschiffen sie dann die
bananenkisten über den nordatlantik und
ihr ziel ist deutschland und dort der
hamburger hafen
jetzt also ein riesengroßer erfolg für
die ermittler fakt ist aber auch es gibt
immer wieder rekord funde die
rauschgiftdelikte in deutschland sie
steigen schauen wir mal auf die zahlen
mit knapp
366.000 taten im jahr sind das ein plus
von 1,7 prozent bei kokain sogar
überproportional plus 9,6 prozent der
anteil deutscher verdächtiger ist in
diesem zusammenhang niedrigsten es kommt
ja eben auch aus dem ausland und einfuhr
ist eben über see und landweg werden
sollen auf der karte gesehen
ja und vor einem supermarkt in bayern
der auch versehentlich mit kokain stadt
bananen beliefert wurde steht jetzt
unser reporter jörg völkerling ob du
hast für uns den prozess auch begleitet
was kannst du uns über die täter sagen
ja diese sechs männer die vor zwei
jahren in landshut vor gericht standen
die machten da den eindruck eines
lustigen völkchen das waren teilweise
verwandte aus derselben albanischen
hafenstadt durres die wohnten in der
gleichen straße und die hierarchie in
dieser bande oder zumindest diese
familienbande bemaß sich daran wer mit
wem verschwägert war wer am nächsten am
oberhaupt dran war und so fanden die
sich alle zusammen letztlich in hamburg
im stadtteil billstedt trafen sich da in
einem café und dort wurden dann die
aufträge sozusagen verteilt die
machart war dann die das sozusagen über
diesen hafen in diesem porto bolivar die
paletten nummern der bananen mitgeteilt
wurden nach deutschland die wurden dann
in hamburg im hafen verteilt auf
verschiedene reifen lagern ganz
deutschland und die albaner mussten dann
nur noch sozusagen in diesen drei
verlagern einbrechen und ganz gezielt
das sah man später auf den überwachungs
kamera aufnahmen nach diesem paletten
suchen und sie entsprechend in taschen
da waren sie haben sie die blöcke diese
braune verpackten glocke eingepackt dann
wieder mitnehmen
trotzdem ist es ja so dass die
bananenkisten dann in den supermärkten
gelandet sind und die verkäuferinnen
dort ja überrascht waren von dieser
menge an koks wie konnte das passieren
ja das ist eine slapstick artige nummer
die bande also diese konkrete
lieferungen ging an das reifenlager von
rewe in einigen das ist bei münchen und
bei google maps ist das reifenlager
direkt neben dem rewe logistikzentrum
aber bei google maps ist das vertauscht
und sechs tage bevor diese zehn
oberbayerischen supermärkte wie dieser
hinter mir in traunreut mit 180
kilogramm kokain beliefert wurden sind
verpackt in bananenkisten gab es einen
einbruch in diesem rewe reifenlager die
diebe waren aber im logistikzentrum
wurde nicht fündig konnten dieses kokain
nicht rausholen und so wurde es dann
ausgeliefert hier in diese in diese rewe
filialen die fahnder wurden dann
natürlich auch aufmerksam und haben mal
gecheckt dass es in den monaten romo
drumrum einbrüche in zehn reifen lagern
in ganz deutschland gegeben hat von
duisburg über dietzenbach in südhessen
bis nach bayern und haben dann einfach
mal nachgeforscht eine funkzellenabfrage
gemacht und haben immer wieder die
gleichen funkzellen immer wieder die
gleichen handydaten festgestellt und
dann begann eine riesige operation mit
dem einsatz von 500 beamten es wurden
700 tausend datensätze
überwachungsmaßnahmen wurden gestartet
und sie erfahren da konnten sozusagen in
echtzeit mithören wie diese albanische
wie diese west balkan mafia
untereinander ganz unverschlüsselt
unverhohlen mit einander gesprochen hat
wo man wann welche einbrüche zu starten
hat und das ging über monate bis dann
letztlich im april 2018 bei einem q in
hamburg gefahren der sich an die werte
dieses umgebauten fiat vivaro hefteten
wo diese fuchs paletten drin verbaut
waren und dann diese bande auf der a 57
bei xanten am niederrhein hobbs genommen
werden konnte ihr vorgänger unser bild
reporter vor ort vielen dank für diese
hintergrundinformationen und
zugeschaltet ist bei uns jetzt auch
benjamin landreau er ist der
pressesprecher bei der gewerkschaft der
polizei berlin wir haben es gehört hallo
herr landreau eine große erfolg der
polizei einerseits andererseits immer
wieder solche funde werden sie dieser
drogenmafia am ende doch nicht her
er scheint erstmal jede substanz die
illegal ist die aus dem verkehr gezogen
wird wo man dahinter kommt ist natürlich
immer ein erfolg für die
sicherheitsbehörden aber man sieht
anhand der zahlen auch und man sieht
auch anhand der funde sehr sehr deutlich
dass wir ne kokain stämme beispielsweise
erleben und auch von anderen substanzen
das also in den letzten jahren ganz ganz
viele drogen auch gerade über den
hamburger hafen nach deutschland
eingeschleust werden und wir eben
oftmals auch von zufallsfunden sprechen
das heißt das kann dann letztlich nur
die spitze des eisberges sein da machen
wir uns auch keine illusion vor deswegen
muss man schon auch ehrlich sein das ist
ein internationales geschäft verstoßen
dann irgendwann auch deutsche
sicherheitsbehörden an ihre grenzen und
so lange die nachfrage da ist wird es
auch immer leute geben die konsumenten
mit nachschub person der schmuggler gibt
es da immer wieder neue maschen
an sich sind die maschen ja seit
jahrzehnten auch relativ gleich also es
ist so dass man kokain ganz gern eben
das wächst im regelfall nicht ein auf
deutschen bäume das heißt das muss dann
aus süd oder mittelamerika auch nach
deutschland gebracht werden nach europa
in gänze und das macht man halt ganz
gerne über den seeweg weil natürlich in
verbindung mit mit obstkisten es gibt ja
auch immer wieder zufallsfunden in einem
aldi-markt oder einem regen haag wo sich
dann so eine kiste verirrt hat ist es so
dass es auch für der für die spürhunde
des zolls beispielsweise gar nicht so
einfach ist das auf dem ersten
schnitzler dann auch zu riechen beide
haben eine begasung da haben wir kühlung
von obst deswegen wurde das ganz gerne
obst kisten verstaut und es ist
einfacher auch als es beispielsweise
über persönliche kuriere über den
luftweg zu tun weil sie natürlich auch
eine masse an kokain ins land bringen
wollen und erreicht hat ein kilo oftmals
nicht auch wenn der verkehrswert mit
rund 50.000 da schon lukrativ ist aber
bei den kunden sehen wir ja es gibt
mehrere hundert kilo die gefunden werden
es gibt tonnen nie gefunden werden
deswegen ist der weg sehr lukrativ und
man muss auch sagen es wird ja nicht
jeder jeder container dann letztlich
kontrolliert deswegen gehen da eben auch
viele sendungen durch daher sind die
maschen relativ ähnlich geblieben und
sie sind halt leider immer noch
erfolgreich wir sprechen jetzt von der
west balkan mafia die dahinter steckt
ist da auch immer wieder ein ähnliches
muster zu erkennen was die täter
betrifft
das ist schon dass wir im gesamten
bereich der organisierten kriminalität
und drogen sind da das schmiermittel was
spektakuläre raubtaten beispielsweise in
der masse dann letztlich auch erdrückt
weil man bekommt hat aufgrund der abgabe
von substanzen und dem großen geld was
man damit verdienen kann kokain ist ja
nur ein beispiel ist es halt ein sehr
lukratives geschäft und ja da und
unterscheidet sich westbalkan lokal
letztlich nicht von anderen
gruppierungen es ist so dass es sehr
lukrativ ist es ist so dass gerade auch
mit drogen gehandelt wird das ist alles
immer internationale netzwerke sind wir
erleben im bereich der organisierten
kriminalität dass wir zunehmend auch
banden haben die sich speziell dann
vielleicht für einen großen chor
zusammen tun was dann auch die
nachverfolgung sehr stemmert und dass
wir ganz ganz viele nationalitäten haben
die da zusammenarbeiten also da steckt
ein breites netzwerk einer großen
logistik dahinter und umso wichtiger ist
dass die dass die sicherheitsbehörden
auch über ein breites netzwerk und eine
gute kommunikation untereinander
verfügen jetzt haben sie ja das
sichergestellte koks an einem geheimen
ort verbrannt wieso darf
naja man muss sich schon
vergegenwärtigen dass das hier auch
substanzen sind die ordentlich geld
reinbringen das heißt potenziell ist das
auch sehr lukrativ dann vielleicht mal
aus dem bereich der organisierten
kriminalität wenn man so im ort kennt wo
das passieren soll und das passiert
nicht von heute auf morgen sondern da
werden drogenfunde von mehreren monaten
von jahren zusammen gefügt und dann
verbrannt wenn man weiß wo das ist dann
müssen wir auch die kolleginnen und
kollegen schützen dass die opfer eines
überfalls beispielsweise werden ich
meine wir reden hier über dreistellige
millionenbeträge teilweise
milliarden-beträge und deswegen ist auch
wichtig dass die sicherheitsbehörden da
den den ort geheim halten das macht man
mit mit personen die die gefährdet sind
ja auch und dementsprechend natürlich
dann auch bei den substanzen und das ist
verbrannt und es gibt jetzt wenig andere
verwendungszwecke für kokain von daher
ist es dann auch richtig das zeug dann
auch vom von der erdoberfläche
verschwinden zu lassen sagt jan o vielen
dank von der gewerkschaft der polizei
danke für die handwerker ich danke ihnen